A digital
first approach to the future of work
is where the industry
and all companies will be heading.
Could the future of work
not be at home or in the office,
but in the metaverse instead?
There's that word.
"Metaverse." "I'm doing well,
how are you doing?
When I think about the metaverse,
I think about immersive experiences
that have a sense of active presence.
Wow. Look at this.
This is me.
The metaverse is projected
to become over a trillion dollar market
by the end of this decade.
And whether you know it or not, you'll
probably be working there in the future.
We're moving into a world
where we're going to be interacting
with computers with our bodies.
This is definitely trippy.
I think the adoption curve
is going to be slow.
It's weird. I'm
a weird, floaty thing right now.
Oh, look at you.
You have no legs. It's
kind of a fun world.
And we're just at the very beginning
of a very long journey.
Now, to properly tell this story,
I felt it was important that I,
A) never leave my home
and B) spend a bit more time
in the metaverse myself
So I got a VR headset.
Tried it on.
Checked it out a little bit.
I actually feel like this is what
I should look like all the time.
And found
someone who's been immersed in AR / VR,
commonly combined and referred to as XR,
since the beginning.
"Oh, it says he's here." What up?
I caught you guys talking about me.
My name is Kent Bye
and I do the voices of VR podcast.
There's a sauna that's upstairs.
We did a scout for the right place
to do the interview.
We considered a hot tub.
Now you're in. Feels great.
But ultimately,
we chose this quiet and comfortable
lounge, complete with the fireplace.
We even created a virtual three camera
shoot with my colleagues, Tom and Jordan.
"I am rolling." It's the gang.
We're getting the band back together.
"I'm rolling on my end." "Cool.
All right. Yeah. Take it away."
I mean,
it's just the whole idea of the avatar.
I find that interesting,
especially in the context of work
and meeting people that we choose
how we're going to be represented.
I mean, I don't know
if I would be a ragdoll bunny rabbit
driving a robot in any other context.
What's happening
is impacting your emotions.
In some ways.
You know, we're in these avatars,
and we have a sense of embodied presence.
But, you know,
we can have the virtual body
ownership illusion
where you start to really own this body
that you have.
When you have that full....
MATT: Kent's
obviously much better at this than me.
You can tell how his hands move
really naturally when he talks.
Whereas mine, well,
they fidgeted and mostly just kind of
folded in on themselves.
Let me ask you, how did the pandemic
change our concept of meeting?
On the onset of the pandemic,
you had all this technology with Skype
and Zoom and everything that had been out
there as infrastructure for a long time.
But most people would prefer to meet
and have that full, rich
and bodied interaction.
But after the pandemic,
pretty much everybody you could meet with.
And so it actually kind of
democratized access to different people.
And I think VR is kind of place
to kind of be in this next phase.
As we move forward.
You know,
we're having this conversation right now
where you didn't
have to come out to Portland, Oregon,
but we can still, you know,
recreate the essence of what would happen
if you would be here.
This concept is being adopted
by a multitude of companies
whose research has found that fully
simulated environments of immersive
learning helped their trainees
retain information better
as it gives them a stronger sense of place
and a more memorable experience overall.
KENT:
Accenture is a huge consulting company.
They hire anywhere from like 60,000
to 100,000 people a year.
They've purchased
60,000 Quests to be able to send out
to be able
to do onboarding into their company.
Whoa. Wait a second.
But what little time I've spent in VR
I couldn't help
but feel like it's more of an escape
rather than a place to work.
And if I'm going to step
into an alternate reality,
I want to fly around, play games
and do things that aren't possible
in the real world,
which doesn't
really include taking meetings.
KENT: I often
find within a lot of those workplaces
they have the most amazing technology
in the world, and then you're in a world
that just makes you feel like you're
in a soulless corporate office.
And you go in there and you're like, "I
totally don't want to be in this space."
MATT: Nevertheless,
there is a mad dash in the tech
sector to create virtual spaces
that are conducive to work.
And some of the largest companies
are leading the charge.
As you probably already know., Facebook
rebranded to Meta,
signaling their intention
to lead in this new virtual world.
So I got myself a slightly more buttoned
up, smoother and younger
looking avatar with much better hair.
Whoa.
That's kind of me.
To check in with Meta's
Senior Product Director Micah Collins.
I assume that you believe
that this is the future of work.
Is that correct?
I believe it is
a part of the future of work.
I think what companies and employees need
is a new common collaboration platform.
I remember how long we used to travel
for a 30 minute meeting
and take the redeye back home.
It's crazy to think about ever
having to do something like that again.
We want to essentially allow a new culture
around collaboration to emerge
where people can kind of be
however they're comfortable,
build a very inclusive product
that still fosters options and the ability
to be as present as you want to be.
"So, uh Barcelona, huh?"
MATT: The gamification of reality
has blurred those lines of what work
really is, how you get work done.
Why are we actually limiting ourselves
and constraining ourselves
to an office environment in the Metaverse?
MICAH: Helping it
feel like a place for work is a key part.
Is it familiar
enough where we can feel like it's
something new, be inspired to be here,
but not be completely distracted by it
so we don't actually get anything done?
I think it is that balance of
like building something special, but also
building it for a purpose with intention
to ultimately
help us focus.
MATT: Let's not forget
that meetings aren't always just talk.
Fields like architecture, product design
or fabrication require hands
on collaborations, something that XR
is poised to take particular advantage of.
MICAH: What does it look like
to sketch a new sneaker design together?
What does it look like to review something
that's being designed?
How do we think about things
like 3D object import from creation
applications, tools that designers use
so that we can actually sit down and
have people look at something together
and redline it in space together
and then export
it for continued development.
NEWS ANCHOR: Video conferences
can be mentally exhausting.
"Many of us are also experiencing a
heightened level of anxiety and fatigue."
MATT: But just as there's zoom fatigue,
there's most certainly bound
to be XR fatigue.
In fact, I kind of already have it
and as intriguing, as all this is my head
kind of hurts.
My eyes are tired.
And in reality,
not every meeting is necessarily
going to have to be this immersive.
MICAH: There may be a headset on my desk
that's ready to go at any point in time.
Let me start the meeting in VC
while I wrap up some texts
and do some other things.
Then all of a sudden it's like, "Oh,
now it's time to put on my headset
and go fully propelled
and immersive into the space."
We want to take that friction away
from moving
between different connection modalities
and just make it really up to the user.
MATT: But as
a new adopter, let me just say
we are not there yet.
The utopia is that it's seamless.
But let me throw a number at you.
Right now, the average
large company uses 188 different apps.
188 I mean, that's kind of insane.
We have tech overload right now.
We're still not even getting Zoom
calls right.
"Didn't
you hear me, Judge?" "I can hear you.
I think it's a filter." I'm here live.
It's not that I'm not a cat.
MATTHEW BOYLE: We're still screwing
those up left, right and center.
And you have people who feel excluded.
You have workers
who are going into the office and spending
all day on Zoom and saying, "Why
did I schlep all the way into the office
just to spend my day on Zoom?"
There's going to be cool experiments.
Of course, there always are.
But, you know, in terms of this
being how we work,
I think we're a little bit far from that
right now.
The adoption curve is going to be slow.
It's going to be painful.
It's going to be expensive.
Companies are already spending
millions of dollars on new benefits
to keep employees
happy and engaged so they don't quit.
So now telling them what we got to be
investing in the metaverse as well,
they're going to say, "Well, what's the
payoff?" "Why should we be doing this.?"
MATT: Back in the old fashioned
physical world,
a bit north of Silicon Valley.,
Microsoft has been actively trying
to solve these more practical problems,
what they deem the hybrid workplace,
a more equitable convergence of the remote
and office worlds.
JARED:
When you think of meetings in the future,
almost every interaction that you have in
person is also going to have
some sort of digital person joining.
They're going to be on the other side
digitally participating.
And so you kind of
have to design your physical space
for people who aren't physically there.
It's our mission
to make sure that remote interactions
are not second class interactions,
that they're first class,
that any time we bring together
the digital with the physical
that we really have
a very rich, multifaceted interaction
that doesn't advantage or disadvantage
anyone.
Because if we can tap into talent
from all over the world, if you don't have
to physically be next to someone in order
to make a difference in an organization
or in order
to make sure that your idea is used,
imagine what we can do for the planet
and for the human family, really.
MATT:
This rethinking of the modern meeting
includes a complete reconfiguration
of everything from technology interfaces
and multiple camera angles to room sizes
and even table shapes.
JARED: Ultimately, what we found
is that the most important thing is
that you have to kind of balance people
seeing and interacting with each other
physically and also being seen
by the digital participants.
And so we have come to shapes
like you see here that allow cameras
to be able to create a separate video
feed for each of the physical participants
that we can then beam over to people
who are attending virtually.
That ends up being the sweet spot
right there.
MATT: Of course, Microsoft
is still betting that XR will be a part
of this future.
Their version of Meta's
metaverse is called Mesh
They also have
an ambitious mixed reality
headset, the HoloLens,
the adoption of which has yet to be wide
enough to project any dominance
in the market, at least partially due
to its very high price tag.
And that very well may be
where Apple comes in.
MARK: Apple is the elephant in the room
when it comes to virtual meetings,
virtual reality and augmented reality
The company for about seven years
now has been working on a VR headset
or a mixed reality headset, augmented
reality headset.
They have people from NASA.
They have people from the video game
industry.
They have people from Hollywood.
They have people who worked
on the original, you know, Macs, iPhones,
iPads, Apple watches,
leading the design of this project
from a software standpoint, a hardware
standpoint, a content standpoint.
MATT: With Apple's
reputation for relatively affordable
consumer products.
There's little doubt
that whatever they drop
will alter the landscape of the metaverse
But while the older kids fight
among themselves in the great tech
sandbox in the sky, we mustn't forget that
the metaverse remains anyone's game.
There's a diverse set of visions out there
that could easily have an impact
on the workplace of the future.
And many of them don't involve AR, VR
or any kind of mixed reality at all.
Desktop versions of meeting places
can achieve similar results
without the adoption issues
or infrastructure
requirements of VR headsets and the like.
ALEX: What we find is companies
that are maybe VR first.
There's that novel kind of cool factor.
But not many people have headsets yet.
That's why we're desktop first
application.
MATT: Virbela is betting that
physical offices of any kind
are a thing of the past.
Offering an entire virtual campus,
complete with everything
from private offices to convention halls,
auditoriums, music
venues, yoga studios, soccer fields.
We even took a boat
ride "Why don't you drive"?" "Oh, wow."
ALEX:
We see environments like this becoming
kind of the hub where large organizations
can come together
and have this united place of
this is our headquarters.
When the pandemic hit,
we were about 20 employees, and today
we're closer to 140.
MATT: Everyone here is hundreds, if
not thousands of miles from one another.
Yet present together
in this virtual campus.
ALEX: Nice, casual place to meet
space gives us again these social cues,
the ability to sit, even though obviously
our avatars aren't getting tired.
We see people getting territorial
about their space.
MATT: At one point,
we crashed a conference
and open the floor up to comments.
I asked people to tell me
where they were physically,
and they were indeed
thousands of miles away from each other.
ALEX:
Wait, who's working from Disney World?
MATT: That is completely insane.
Well, thanks, everybody.
Thanks for letting us interrupt
your meeting here.
Just the idea that someone could clock
in work hours while at the Magic Kingdom
kind of blew my mind.
Here was someone able to balance work
and pleasure in a way that was unthinkable
a few years prior.
But after about 2 hours
inside this campus, I couldn't help
but recall what Kent told me
about the state of virtual workplaces.
KENT: You're in a world
that just makes you feel like you're
in a soulless corporate office.
You go in there and you're like, "I
totally don't want to be in this space."
MATT: Whereas I do
get the idea that work needs
to stay grounded
in some sort of analog of reality.
There's a part of me
that just wants to abandon all constraints
of the physical world.
And that thinking led me quite literally
"Nowhere." What's up, buddy?
Welcome to Nowhere.
JON: This is a virtual 3D metaverse
platform.
But Nowhere, we're not about recreating
reality, like
by putting buildings and office
rooms and board spaces.
We're about creating environments
that really inspire different emotions
and different feelings about
how do you want to feel
when you're in these enviroments?
Actually, why don't I take you to where
I love to have my meetings?
Nice. There we go.
MATT:
Nowhere embraces magical realism
as its backdrop.
It's decidedly avatar free web based,
and for lack of a better word,
kind of anti-VR.
Instead, they've constructed a platform
that takes the best of both video
conferencing and virtual spaces
JON: For us, there's
nothing like the presence of....
of humans.
When you're on a zoom call. It's
just a flat grid.
You know, you see the people's faces,
but there's no sense of presence.
But within Nowhere,
you have that added sense of place
that it allows you to create memories.
You know, we're looking at each other.
We're able to see all the subtlety
of facial expression,
which is based on thousands
and thousands of years of evolution of us
instinctually, you know, looking for signs
of how we read people's faces
and how we read people's body behavior.
When I'm in VR,
I feel disconnect from people
and I feel disconnect from the world.
You know, some of my most exciting moments
in life are when I'm with humans.
I don't believe that cartoon avatars are
going to create the feeling of co presence
and the feeling of intimacy
that we need within work environments
to trust each other,
to collaborate freely, and to really build
relationships that build great
teams, that build great products.
MATT: Regardless of Jon's hard line
stance on avatars.
It seems obvious that XR is not going away
The AR / VR and mixed reality sectors
combined
is expected to grow
into a $100 billion market by 2025.
And with the availability
of more affordable headsets, adoption
is really a matter of when not if.
MARK: The next paradigm is really
these augmented reality, mixed reality
and virtual reality ecosystems.
And right now it seems
that Meta is going to be at the forefront
so you're going to see a wide array of
people probably using those Meta headsets
for video conferencing.
More people at home
will be able to get their hands on it.
And at some point, Apple's become a big
deal too, for the future of virtual work.
MATT: I'm
still wrapping my head around all of this.
VR and the like,
fully replacing our physical reality
isn't likely to happen anytime soon.
But as alternative realities of every type
seep into our homes and offices,
be them virtual or otherwise,
it's safe to say that this will not be
our last meeting in the Metaverse.
Guys, this has been really fun.
I think we should.
I think we should do this again.